de paria a socio este viernes yo byd en
visita a arabia saudita una nación a la
que se había comprometido a aislar en la
escena internacional tras la muerte de
llamar a shocks y el periodista saudita
asesinado en el consulado de su país en
turquía según la prometida del
periodista la visita del presidente
estadounidense es una traición
es un gran paso hacia atrás es
desgarrador
es decepcionante y al poner el petróleo
de los contratos por encima de los
principios y los valores
joe biden está perdiendo su autoridad
moral
ante las críticas badén publicó un texto
en el washington post para explicar los
motivos de su visita y defendió su
decisión en una rueda de prensa
sobre el caso hat soy y mi posición
siempre ha sido muy clara
pero la razón por la que voy a arabia
saudita va mucho más allá voy a defender
los intereses de eeuu
en 2019 antes de ser elegido presidente
joe biden acusó directamente a mohamed
bin salman de ser el autor intelectual
del asesinato de hash oxy pero con la
guerra en ucrania eeuu necesita el apoyo
de riad para aumentar la producción
mundial de petróleo los observadores
afirman que la marcha atrás es una
victoria para la monarquía saudí